simply keep asking the question without
reaching for the answer so the question
might be what is my purpose right and
the goal was just to Simply keep saying
what is my purpose what is my purpose
what is my purpose without trying to
reach for the purpose CU when we reach
we're often reaching for something like
an occupation or something in the
tangible world it's too contextualized
in the world but when we just ask and
like wait for me what came to mind was
like hugging 21-year-old girls and
saying this is going to sound weird and
saying everything's going to be okay and
like everything's going to be okay and
everything's going to be okay and like
that's not a job but it felt like a
purpose to help people feel okay